[Music]
hello good human
we just wanted to say thank you
thank you all for your support and for
watching our video
[Music]
giving for something
and that's my portion of all our profits
will go towards our new human good fund
where we'll be giving back to some of
the most inspiring good humans doing
good for the world
[Music]
okay in the goodbye
enjoy the episode
why don't we talk about hobbies i do
yoga
we brought together seven white people i
am white i am white
i am white i am white i am white
i am white i am black
one is a liar while blindfolded if the
group discovers who the liar is they'll
split a cash prize
if the liar survives she wins the entire
prize
[Music]
i got walked into the box i was really
scared
but i was really confident that i was
going to win because i practiced
also i have a naturally white voice
clearly i'm not white people probably or
do think i talk white because i was
adopted
and both of my parents are white oh okay
i'm
anna i'm the first person in okay fine
and then i'm brandon i'm
second person in line i'm ryan and i'm
the third person in line
i'm mariah and i'm the fourth person in
line i'm elizabeth and i'm the fifth
person in line
i'm kylie and i'm the sixth person in
line i'm cody i'm the
seventh person in line why don't we talk
about hobbies
okay i'll start i um i do yoga
oh i don't know no black people do yoga
too come on i do yoga too
wait so you're black no you just said
that yeah you you you
you just responded to that's number i
think i'm looking at you i can't tell
but
that's anna i think you are looking anna
anna right yeah this isn't
interesting what was your tactic
i think my tactic was just to try to be
as friendly as possible
i was going based off names what's your
last name mariah ford
like the car what about a truck or like
the truck
my last name is pinto like the car wait
that's crazy wait you said your last
name is pinto yeah like
like the bean bean yeah oh yeah i like
the bean too it is pinto or the horse
i think there's a bit of a culture that
i mean of course there's
a lot more of a culture that i think
that black people have that white people
don't
draw on a blank hair i don't know if you
ask
all i know is that if you ask questions
you might be able to find something what
kind of uh what kind of music do you
guys listen to
oh don't get me wrong i love justin
bieber justin bieber
i love justin bieber you're getting
voted on just for that [ __ ] i don't be
rude i love him this what wait is this
kylie
right here no she's trying to play a
part i think yeah i love
justin bieber i do love justin bieber i
love him
my tactic in this game was to be as
white as possible
no what about like like red hot chili
peppers and like back in the day
like that stuff is like like i won't
turn it off if it's on but
wait the red hot chili pepper singing
sing like tonight
tonight no is that fun no is it it's a
party
oh yeah you're white you're a wife
i don't think music is a really good
telltale sign to say who is black or
white
my best friend she's black and she loves
country i listen to
predominantly rap i rap a little myself
if you know me personally and i'm white
so i mean i i really i mean i listen to
the radio once in a while but i'm a
podcast person
okay what kind of podcast i don't know i
feel like this is like
the type of music you listen to can
depict like
you know what your upbringing is it
doesn't necessarily have to be race but
i think there's a lot of
people who are of color that have a lot
in common as far as they listen to music
goes
i swear if you put your hands up man you
guys are so wrong
tell me right now it was actually really
hard to try and figure out
who it was just based on like the voices
and the things that they would say
you cannot vote twice kylie
that was the name that i felt like it
wasn't as white
in my opinion i don't know why but i was
suspicious of cody
like i i was pretty sure i was right
bye kylie bye kylie i guess
because of my name i don't think that i
really like
said enough to like have a solid vote i
wasn't really sure
about kylie being voted out i wasn't
really sure why other people voted her
out
i was just happy that i wasn't voted out
i didn't really know people's names but
it doesn't really matter because
yeah i'm trying to picture like
everyone's what they look like from
their voice and like i low-key think we
already
got somebody off of my tripping out or i
had no idea
if ever if people were on the same track
as me mentally or not
you think that what was the name kylie
the mole yeah you think that she i think
so that's who i voted for in all honesty
i've i've been wrong before but i'm
pretty sure yeah that's who i voted for
what are your guys's favorite foods
it's probably sushi like all you can eat
sushi
i like the california rolls because it
has the crab you can also get like those
baked rolls
you know like dumplings no like
[Laughter]
no i said baked rolls who said dumplings
is this elizabeth right here yeah
elizabeth oh my god all right
now what did you got and i think this is
the burning question that we've all been
thinking
what did you guys think of black panther
i actually didn't watch the movie
that's really because a lot of people
said it was good i wish it was a little
bit more gory
that was very popular among people of
color it's a great movie
i loved it if you watch black panther
that doesn't make you
white or black like that was a huge
movie one person saw black panther not a
lot of people did but i
i did that to for a goof oh i've seen
black panther
disclaimer loved black panther it was
iconic
i didn't see black panther star-lord
yeah
what are your guys's
girl i'm in school i i'll barely even
get to have time to read to myself
my favorite well the play i'm reading
right now is all my sons by arthur
miller
chapter one what's that one about it's
about this
dude who went to prison and like the mom
still believes that their son is alive
and i haven't finished they didn't hear
too much from her so there was a bit of
mystery there
maybe maybe a little bit of her voice
yeah i was shocked i think it was the
yoga comment
black people do yoga too come on i do
yoga too it was just
horrible timing so i'll start since i'm
at the end now
where anna was uh this is brandon wait
so is the mole gone
that's what i'm i've i kind of thought
it was kylie hey brandon hey what's up
man
okay um a cop pulls you over
um what do you do it literally just
happened to me like
two weeks ago was it for speeding it was
the privilege you saw the privilege
you could smell it no it was actually uh
my front license plate
he's like i'm just going to give you a
warning it really bothers me that i'm
like
when somebody is actually getting pulled
over for doing something and
they're not getting ticketed but
somebody of another race could get
pulled over for the same thing
and they would get a ticket you know he
gave you a warning
yeah he gave me a warning you're white
yeah if i were to be honest i've gotten
followed home in my town
so many times and they're doing it
because i'm one of few black people in
my
hometown they should know me by now like
there's a few of us come on
cody yeah okay i got your name right um
why are your hands sweaty because i'm
blindfolded and i think that's like a
like so you're so you're ranked you're a
little anxious i don't
elizabeth
suspecting elizabeth she didn't really
talk much
there is a tie brandon and elizabeth
i was trying to save myself if you want
to vote for brandon
raise your hand because he was very
outspoken
i believed that he wasn't the mole
because i feel like
if i was in a place and i was the mole i
would try to keep
it down my profile
you guys messed up
come on man look at me
i feel like the smaller the pool of
people the more likely you are to win
raise your hand if you would like to
continue
if the lights turned green you voted the
liar out
if the lights turned red the wire is
still in the box
and you lose
[Applause]
girl i knew it i knew it guys
who's brandon brandon i have beef with
you you were on to me from the start
you're elizabeth huh my real name's
elizabeth but i go by lisey
oh my god elizabeth that's a white
[ __ ] [ __ ] i know
i was suspicious of elizabeth for just
one second
whenever she would talk it was something
stereotypical white that of the
white people i know i came here to
collect my coins
[Music]
oh my gosh this is my dream oh my gosh
this is literal oh my gosh
thank you being blindfolded for so long
was way weirder than i thought it was
going to be
my race is human when it comes to race
you really can't
judge a person based off what they like
a song
or artist or food that they enjoy
hey y'all thank you so much for watching
that episode of odd men out we hope you
loved it
and also just a quick reminder head over
right now to humangoodla.com
to check out the new collection
collection 3. it's our favorite one yet
and we know that you'll love it
for anyone who orders more than 75 worth
of clothing
we're actually gonna send you guys a
free gift just for a limited time so
check that out
make sure you leave a comment below hit
the like button
[Music]